yeah what's what's the craziest thing
that you have done to make weight so
cutting weight
uh you don't know but I'm like uh let me
pause pause let me think if I can no you
already have it you have to tell us
those are the rules
oh man
this is uh
I
ah [ __ ] hold up [ __ ] hell okay
you have to tell us like you can't you
can't do this I know I was trying to
think you know so much about you now
what is the crazy thing
well back in kickboxing back in the day
when I was an amateur when I was really
young and had no I didn't have to fight
dietitian who's the guy that looks after
us here with my meals on whatnot I did
not have him
on Deck I wasn't in the UFC
ah [ __ ] man
okay I um
how do I put the I I busted enough to
make way
okay rewind let's not go to that story
bro
[Laughter]
you really wanted to know
this is the thing yeah because at the
time I was young and I was on that whole
no before a fight before I knew it was a
myth
and yeah I just and then the few grams
came off 100 grams you made weight yeah
wow
this is the
stuff
but I wouldn't advise it hey I was
younger back then it's like 21 22. I
didn't know what I was doing with weight
cutting
and yeah that was uh yeah that was
something